Welcome everybody to toxic Google.
It's my great pleasure to
introduce Leslie Stall,
one of our country's most
preeminent journalists.
She has been a correspondent
at 60 minutes for 25 years.
And his covered pretty much everything
that's happened in the world in the last
quarter century for one
ton amount to all the wars,
to various presidential campaigns,
to technology stories,
which is a particular area of
interest of hers to sports. Um,
she is the winter of 11.
Any awards and prior to joining,
60 minutes was a White House
correspondent during the Carter and Reagan
administrations and it was a
moderator of face the nation.
She is the author of two books, including
the one that is on sale in the back, um,
called, um, becoming grammar.
So highly encourage everybody to pick
up a signed copy of the book on your way
out. Great Mother's Day gift.
So get your shopping done early.
There's also cards back there,
so feel free to get it done in one stop.
And she is,
is
the proud grandmother of two girls.
Welcome Leslie. Thank you. So me,
she neglected to say so many neglected
to say that we're colleagues because Sumi
worked at 60 minutes till
less than a year ago. Yes.
I was a producer and we worked together
and had the pleasure of working with
Leslie on a couple of stories. That's
great. So, um, tell me about the book.
Did becoming a grandmother surprising?
Well,
I knew I was going to be a grandmother.
What surprised me was the
enormity of that initial emotion,
this kind of wallop of love that's unlike
any other kind of loving that any that
you have for any other creature on the
planet. It's nothing like mother love.
It's its own, it's its own little animal.
And when you become a grandmother,
you change so dramatically that
your children don't recognize you.
They run around saying, who is
she? Because you are so mush.
Bali, you are just a puddle
of, of whatever the kid wants.
I believe that we are actually,
uh,
that the word no is incapacitated.
We cannot deny them anything.
Um,
but,
but really it was that initial jolt of
elation and emotion that I wanted to
explore. What is that? Do
all grandmothers have that?
The answer is most of them do.
The grandfathers have it, they do,
but it's different.
And uh,
and look into the history,
the biochemistry,
the anthropology,
the different kinds of grandmothers step,
grandmother's surrogate,
grandmother's, uh,
and even when there's tension
in the family with the
daughter-in-law and there's
a lot of tension with the daughter.
I wrote it as much for your
generation as for my generation,
for young parents because
we're in this together,
young parents and their parents
were the family. And so I,
it's as geared for my daughter who is a
young woman with two kids as it is for
my friends.
So as I was reading the book, the
thing that was most enlightening to me,
so I'm the mother of a young
daughter who's six years old,
but it really gave me a look into what
my mom must be experiencing and how she
comes to it and things that I feel
like can be a little metal somewhere.
I'm like, mom, I'm not going to
do that when you're talking about.
And so it was really a, an interesting
kind of insight. And does sheet metal,
sorry, does your mother metal,
she very carefully it metals.
She's very cautious about it.
Well what, so what do you, I mean,
I don't think of modern parenting.
I'll tell you what I
think of modern parenting.
But first let me say that
most grandmothers I met and
interviewed including me,
we walk on eggshells.
We are so careful.
We don't want our kids to be angry at us
because then we fear they might deny us
access to the only thing that really
matters anymore. And it's those babies.
So I had any number of grandmothers I
interviewed and I interviewed a lot,
tell me, you know, my tongue
hurts from biting or uh, I,
he,
I won't even lift an eyebrow in
criticism of how they're doing it.
And then the minute you leave the house,
you turned to your husband or
he turns to you and you say,
we didn't do it that way. And she turned
out okay. You know, we were good at it.
Well, the truth is we weren't as
good at it as your generation is.
That's the truth.
Okay.
But I think that puts more
pressure on parents as well.
Right now you're so concerned
about they can't eat this.
They have to go to bed at a certain time.
You have to follow the routine.
It's a lot more, I mean,
how did you manage that? You
had such a demanding career.
How did you manage it when your
daughter was younger? Well, I think
my generation of women was much more
focused on just getting into the workplace
and it took a lot of energy
and a lot of attention.
We missed a lot with our
children that we regret. Um,
I think we are,
our attention was,
was truly divided and I think
our children, you, my daughter,
um, a lot of the people who work at
Google by the age I'm looking out at here,
um, you learn from us or
maybe resent what we did,
but you're doing it differently. And the
truth is, I admire the way you're doing.
I admire the way my daughter is putting
a lot of emphasis on her family.
Although she has a big job,
but she's still,
she's still is more,
she's building a better nest than I did.
I admit that.
And what are the things that you noticed
that you have to bite your tongue for?
Not necessarily that your daughter,
but I'm telling you one,
I'll tell you when sleep training,
I don't know how many people
here have children. Have you?
Well, tell us what's, no,
I know, but at Google in
general, but, but I did,
I didn't sleep train so
I'd never heard of it.
Apparently it's been around for ages.
So the idea is after a couple of months
you just let the baby scream and yell.
And I just happened to be there when it
happened with my husband and I couldn't
stand it. They didn't pick her up, they
just let her scream or little header.
I skin was crawling,
but I didn't say a single word.
I just sat on it.
I was hyperventilating.
I was thought I was having a heart attack,
but I didn't say a word.
We get in the car because
we were staying at a hotel.
I husband turns to me and says,
what was that all about? And I said,
what? I said, I didn't say a
word. I was the Sphinx. He said,
you didn't say a word.
You didn't shut up the whole time.
So out of my mouth was, why are you
punishing her? Why are you making herself?
I swear I didn't think I said a
word and it was just tumbling out.
I didn't hear myself weird.
I know.
But for the most part,
my generation of parents is sitting on
it or trying to sit on it because we want
you to think that we think you're
wonderful so that you'll let us have the
babies.
And so tell me a little bit about some
of the signs that you found out about as
you were researching this book.
What is the science behind grandparenting?
What is this thing that's
happening? Well, there's,
there's two interesting things above
all the others. One is the biochemistry.
Um,
that enormous wallop that I felt and it,
I felt it all over my body is
actually a biochemical response.
When a mother has a baby,
her brain is completely rewired and all
kinds of different new hormones come
into play. Uh, grandmother has
something somewhat similar.
She is on her brain,
is also rewired,
not as extensive knitly
and not as dramatically,
but she also see creates
a bonding hormone.
And so she is physically binding
herself to that little baby.
Just the way parents do.
Well,
it's not the way parents do
because it's not as intense.
But we also go through a connection that
holds us to that baby so that when we
don't see the baby,
we crave the baby.
And it can happen to a step grandmother.
It can happen to a surrogate grandmother.
It can happen to an aunt, a great aunt.
But when that baby is a little kid and
somebody who thinks of it as somewhat,
there's a holds it,
there's all kinds of physical changes that
go on within you. So that's one thing.
I thought it was pretty interesting.
Oh, here's another thing.
The circuitry of baby loving in
the brain and in the body, the ser,
the wires are exactly the
same wires as romantic love.
They're the same pathway.
So what was happening to me and all other
grandmothers is we're falling in love.
We are literally actually falling
in love and it feels like that.
And it's the, we use language
like that. People say,
I fell off a cliff when
I held my grandchild,
or you feel just wonderful all over.
Or I crave them when they're not there.
So it is exactly the same animal,
the feelings.
And the other thing I found out was
that most animals on the planet die when
they can no longer reproduce.
So when a female stops being
able to have babies, she,
if she can walk or fly,
whatever,
she goes over there and
dies except for elephants,
whales, and humans. So why,
why do we have extended
lives beyond menopause?
Why do we even have menopause? Well, the
answer is to take care of the babies.
Grandmothers raise the babies.
Both parents hunted.
They went out into the fields and raise
crops and they left the babies home with
grandma.
And so I think there is in us kind of
atavistic granular need to re to help
raise the babies when we don't. We,
we heard. And so you talk about it.
I mean it's almost like
we're coming full circle.
You talked about granny nannies.
What her granny nannies tell us granny
nannies are grandmothers who take care of
the babies two days a week,
three or four days a
week to help their kids.
And today in this country
now with post recession,
both parents are working and they're
not making as much as my gender.
One person made my generation.
So you need the help because childcare,
good childcare is exorbitantly expensive.
I'm not telling anybody anything they
don't know it can cost as much as college.
So the babysitting function is
needed and my generation is spending.
Here's the s statistic I came upon.
My generation is,
is spending seven times
more on grandchildren then
grandparents did 10 years
ago. Wow. And we're not,
I'm not talking about toys,
I'm talking about the crib. I'm
talking about the, the car seat.
I mean major items. We're sending the
kids to school, we're paying medical,
we're straightening their teeth.
Um,
grandparents are really
contributing in many ways.
Where does grandpa fit into all
of this? Oh, Grandpa, if you, if,
if grandma's think that we go
through a sea change, which we do,
our personalities change when
we're with those children.
I mean our kids with our kids,
we were policemen and with
our grandchildren were
playmates, whatever they want.
Grandfather's also go through this huge
metamorphosis for a grandfather who
worked very hard when the little ones,
his own little ones who are growing up,
they all think about it as a second
chance to watch a child grow up to be in
their lives.
And a lot of grandmothers told me,
GRANDPA's a better babysitter than I am.
He's more patient,
he's more playful grandparents.
Grandfathers.
I saw this over and over.
Grandfathers are the nanny's,
not grandmothers and many marriages.
The husband is older,
he retires,
grandma's still working.
So he's the one who's taking
care of the babies and um,
he's doing a great job and he loves it.
And if he has health problems,
the children are alleviating them there.
They're getting rid of depression,
they're staving off dementia.
I mean these are,
these are actually studies that
show that, that, that, that,
that baby's just have this effect on us,
makes us healthier,
makes us happier. It makes
us younger. Hmm. I know,
um, to segue a little bit, it
is election season after all,
and all the presidential candidates
are grandparents. So I have to ask you,
what do you make of the,
uh, the race so far?
Well, one, I actually thought
age was going to be an issue. Um,
when Hillary Clinton announced,
I thought that the Republicans were
going to come in with a whole coterie of
younger candidates and they were just
going to harp and bang away at her being
in her late sixties.
Ah, I mean, Bernie 74,
she's only 68, and I think that, uh,
how do we know how all Trump has
to see 69, something like that. Um,
I was very interested in Hillary being
a grandmother because when I started
working on the book, she announced
that she was pregnant and we, I mean,
her daughter was,
yeah,
pregnant. Whoa. It's not the
national inquirer. That's a lead.
And so I was curious.
Yes.
Uh, as to whether her being a
grandmother, well, whether she'd use it,
um, and whether it would help her
are not to win the presidency.
So I went with Frank Luntz,
who's a Republican pollster
to New Hampshire to sit down,
sit in on a focus group,
and uh,
he tacked on a couple of questions for
me and then let me ask some questions.
So they were all Republicans
and he got up there and he said,
what one word would you use
to describe Hilary Clinton?
Oh, God, this was if Hillary
Clinton had been in the room,
she would crawl up in a ball and
go sit in the closet. Dishonest,
liar, cold. Uh, not she did,
they didn't say corrupt,
but that's what they're,
that's what Trump is picking up on.
But words like that, all negative,
all having to do with dishonesty.
It was brutal.
Then he let me get up and I asked
what one word comes to mind when I say
grandmother. Oh my gosh. The
words were just, all of them.
Nobody had one even remotely
negative thing to say. It was loving,
cozy cookies,
unconditional love lap,
warm. So I asked them. Now
they're all republicans.
If they thought, if Hillary played
up that she's a grandmother,
some of those words would
rum up rub off on her.
And I was surprised because they were
all self described as conservative
Republicans.
Several of them,
many of them said they thought it
would help her as long as she didn't.
They said exploit the
child. Meaning, you know,
walk around with the kid on her hip.
Um,
I'm sure Hillary's people have
done their own focus groups.
I'm a little surprised she
hasn't made more of it.
It could be that all the other candidates
are also grandparents. I don't know.
But I,
that focus group led me to believe that
it would soften her image and she's
still having those words come up in all
focus groups, including with Democrats.
So she could use a little, yeah. Yeah.
People never make much out of
grandfathers. Grandmothers.
It's going to be the word in front of
every woman who's ever had a position of
authority. She's a grandmother, but
grandfather's don't get that right.
That's kind of vague. I know. What do
you make of Trump? The Trump phenomena.
Oh my goodness. I mean,
I'm like everybody else.
I don't know what to make of it.
I,
it's not that I don't
know what to make of him.
I don't know what to make of
the public reaction to him.
I could go through a litany of things he
has said where I was sure I would have
put money down that it was over.
I mean,
when he went after John McCain
saying he wasn't a hero.
Now that was really early on.
I knew for sure that was the end.
I knew it well have been
13, 14, 15 of those.
And he always rises from the ashes.
So, uh, I wouldn't dare predict,
and it's even hard to analyze,
but I'm sh I'm,
I know I'm pretty darn sure,
pretty darn sure it's going to
be Hillary versus Trump and, uh,
they're really going to
do jobs on each other.
It's really going to be a slug
fest of gigantic proportion who,
who can slime. The other one
more is probably going to win.
Isn't that awful to say about our country?
The other thing that strikes
me about this campaign,
and I think I've been
struck by it in the past,
but never so intensely is how few people
give the candidates to us.
If you go out and count all the people
who either went to a caucus or voted in a
primary, it's a minute fraction
of the American adult population.
And so the process just doesn't,
it's not working. It's just not,
we have to fix it, just
have to fix it. And I mean,
the thing that strikes me as a former
journalist is how do you report on
somebody like Trump when there's no fact
checking? And I know it's 60 minutes,
very particular, every script is
footnoted, everything is back check.
How do you cover a candidate in a
responsible way who really can't be fact
checked or doesn't carry, is fact
checked, but the public doesn't care.
There are any number of newspaper
columns written about what he got wrong,
television stories written, uh, Don about
what he got wrong. And people don't care.
That's why I say it's the reaction to him.
That's the unfathomable part of it.
Uh,
it's very difficult to
report on him. He, he, I've,
I've studied his
interviews cause you know,
I used to do face the nation and I used
to love to try and pin someone down.
If they didn't want to answer,
ask answer the first question you went to
the second question. And then, you know,
if you go to the third year nagging,
but I would knack,
he's unnavigable you,
you can't,
you just can't get him to answer the
question. He, he gets away from it.
So it's hard. I mean, and where is the
line between entertainment and journalism?
As you said,
if this is going to turn into a slug fest,
it almost feels like a little bit of a,
of, of a horse race, the boxing match,
whatever you want to call it.
I mean, how's about standup
comedy? I know, seriously,
have anybody have,
have any of you just sat
and watched a Trump rally?
None of you. He is hilarious.
He is. Seriously hilarious.
It is. It is a standup routine. And, uh,
I always thought that humor was really,
really important in politics because I
covered Reagan and he was very funny,
but sweetly funny but funny.
Um,
I also thought likeability was crucial
at certainly crucial to leadership to
governing.
Um,
but we are being presented by this tiny
sliver of the country with candidates
who are more unlikeable and candidates
I think have ever been as well in,
in time that we know of. Certainly
in modern time the negatives, oop,
trumps are sick.
He's,
he has an unfavorable rating of 67% and
Hillary and anybody want to guess 56%
negative. And so as you said, you
covered Reagan for a long time.
What do you make of the almost
deification of Reagan? Yeah.
Um, well he wasn't deified
in the beginning at all.
In fact,
there's a little bit of similarity.
There was a huge chunk of the
country because Reagan was very,
very,
very conservative for that period of
time in our history who thought Never
Reagan.
So there was that huge chunk
of the population out there
though the election was
very close.
Then he was shot early on and he handled
that with such grace and really heroism
that he won everybody's heart and people
stopped and stop looking at him in a
two dimensional way.
As a guy who stood for these issues and
started to see the human being and he
had a quality and it's a quality.
We're not seeing this time in anybody.
He had sweetness.
He had a special quality of sweetness.
And when you saw him,
you could disagree with
him 100% and like him.
And it goes a huge long way to govern
when you need to persuade people.
Is the era of sweetness over you think
is there no room left in our, oh,
well I would never say that
we're going to, you know,
when Jimmy Carter was president, every,
there was so much gloom and doom.
Reagan used to run around the country
saying what's with the gloom and doom?
But there was, we were very
pessimistic. Uh, nothing was working.
There were gas lines,
there were food lines for people.
People were suffering so much.
They were standing in line to get food.
We had high inflation,
high unemployment,
you never thought it was going to turn
around and Reagan came in and pretty
soon, you know, we, we were feeling
good again. The economy cranked back up.
So I mean these things are cyclical.
I think we might have sweetness
again when you get home.
I want to bring you back to something
you were saying earlier about Hillary
Clinton being a grandmother.
And one of the interesting things to bring
it back to your book as well was, uh,
when you wrote about how being a
grandmother actually helps women break the
glass ceiling. Well, it's a little bit
about that. Okay. Uh, first of all,
you, you will observe that women in
high places today, a grandmother's,
uh,
Nancy Pelosi,
when she was a sworn in as
speaker of the house. She's your,
was she your, is she? Yeah.
Do you remember then you,
you all remember she,
she had all her grandchildren on the
stage with her and I actually did a story
on her.
She ruled in a maternal way.
She ruled the house with an iron fist,
but a maternal iron fist. Like the mother,
the police woman,
um,
she had an instinct that said the,
that grandmother image can
be a formula for authority.
And so I,
I came to see that while
it's still difficult for the
country as a whole and for
men specifically to accept a young
woman in a position of authority,
it's not hard to except the grandmother
because very often in our families they
were the, they were the tough
one in the family. And um,
so I had a girlfriend
tell me,
she ran a girls school in New York
and for her she was there forever.
She stayed at that school and ran that
school for years and years and years.
She always had trouble with the fathers.
They will always interface telling
her what to do and poking at her.
And one day it just stopped.
It just stopped.
And she was able to control the meeting
with the father and everything was
wonderful. And then she realized that
he was seeing her not as a young,
sexy woman, but as a grandmother.
And so the Cha, you know,
his need to fight with her or to
challenge her stand up to her was over.
So grandmothers can be
authoritative in the public's eye.
Um, and again, I'm surprised
Hillary's and playing it up more.
And you know,
grandmothers aren't old anymore.
They're baby boomers and
baby boomers are young.
They think of themselves are young as
themselves, as young. They act young,
they dress young, they look
young. We, I believe me,
we're tired and told me that when I chase
after my grandchildren, I'm very tired,
but we put on a good face, another
grandmother in the audience laughing.
And uh,
so I don't think we have the same
image that grandmothers had when I was
certainly when I was growing up or
maybe even when you were growing up.
And so here in,
in the valley and we talk a lot about
diversity in tech and um, sort of,
uh,
making sure that there's representation
of women on teams and especially in the
more technical fields with a little
bit of distance and perspective.
What do you make of that, especially
given your research? Well, I'll tell you,
this happened at 60 minutes
too. While you were there. I,
I,
I fear so often that women take two
steps forward and a step and a half back.
We take three steps forward and two steps
back and it's been that way ever since
the women's movement
in the early seventies.
We think we're making progress in the
workplace and then we find out that we're
still only making 79
cents to the man's dollar.
Um, we still don't crash
through the glass ceiling.
We still don't have many CEOs and it's,
it's a bafflement.
It's a bafflement that we don't
have more women in position,
a position positions, um, uh,
of executive positions where they're
making the big decisions when it's shown
that women make better decisions in many
situations and where women are better
educated generally speaking,
as many PhDs and so forth.
So it's a bafflement and uh,
it's a like a little lake.
Cause I was there at the beginning of the
women's rights movement where I was so
sure,
so sure that women were
just going to sweep into,
into the presidency,
into the boardrooms,
into the executive suites in
huge numbers within 30 years.
And it's more than 40 years ago
that this started. So I don't know,
I keep saying the time will come,
but when's that going to cop?
If there are any questions
in the audience, please feel
free. And in the meantime,
I guess two things. First of all, it
regarding women, I think that, uh,
there was a change, not enough, but there
is a change and maybe I'm an optimist,
but, uh, it seems like it's
shifted from end of the wall.
Doesn't let women do
anything, uh, to that,
that as well. But also I think
that education back at home,
I think parents should change as well.
Not just, uh, not just the world,
not just a corporation.
Corporations. I think that steel,
many homes not even
intentionally are not raising eh,
the, the girls, you know, way that
they even understand that, uh,
there are options other than being
a girl or whatever it means that we
experience.
I think we as parents are at least
some of us not doing the best job,
not necessarily because we don't want to,
but because we're not aware of it because
we grew up even my generation in a
way, the two women has, uh, you know,
you grow up in Israel and then in
the United States later, but in,
but in Israel than they
think that it's still,
I saw a lot of conservative type of homes.
And again,
not because they wanted to
underwrite, eh, in Israel,
but also I think that they see it
here that it's conservative in,
in a way that nobody said that
you cannot be an engineer,
but it's not the point. And
I mean, we don't, we don't,
we're not talking about a
girl as an engineer. And
my talking about it being told,
having a girl being told you
can be whatever you want,
that should be the message. I can
cheat. It's very common even today.
And not because the parents are
objecting to it, but they still,
it's very conservative that
girls or girls and boys or boys,
and at least what I'm trying to do,
because nobody has a golden, uh,
uh, is girls can be
girls, boys can be girls,
but I'm trying to mix and match.
So at this she knows she can do,
she can do whatever she wants.
And
that's hard. I come from
obviously different generation.
I was told I could be anything I want.
Right.
And so I'm a little surprised to hear
you say all these generations later,
you don't think that that message is
still being sent to our kids because that
would be a message that comes
down from my generation.
Look at Google, uh, the
numbers that were released,
the public shows that even Google
where we're doing whatever we can to,
to, to, to get as many women as
we can, especially engineers.
There's not enough women graduating
universities in computer science.
That's the parents really. I
thought that was odd. The parents,
girls thinking boys won't like them
if they go into science kind of thing.
I think that it's indirect.
And again, I don't think that,
that a lot of the parents
are doing this in purpose.
I think that in many cases
they don't even think about it.
And at least in my case,
I think about that.
I don't know if I'm doing the right thing,
but I think about that and if anyone was,
will convey any other
message to my daughter,
that's one of the things that can
really freak me out. So that's,
that's a for everybody
who's listening. Yeah. Um,
thank you.
And if we can go back to television,
but television was always my dream,
especially in youth.
So I wanted to be a newscaster.
Always there are in Israel
here. This is the, uh, the mic.
Uh, and I even sometimes I report to
Israeli television, but just as a,
as a, as a side hobby and, but,
but what I did learn from reporting
to radio and television needs,
road foot,
let's say 30 times in my life,
that it's just unbelievable
what happens when something,
something is broadcasted.
No one is watching broadcast television.
Double quote. Nobody old
boy, a video on demand.
It's all Hulu or Netflix.
Nobody's watching anything on TV.
TV is dead and everything.
Once my piece was broadcasted
on television, I mean the, my,
my cell phone was drained out of battery
from so many Facebook came. It's just,
so my question to you is,
how do when you go into a studio,
not even reporting for, from the
field today, after so many years,
what do you feel when you
record in studio, when,
when you see a piece that you did,
what does it make you feel and what do
you think the impact today versus a few
years ago?
I guess the thing that
I feel is that I'm not,
I, I'm not sure I'm having an
impact and it bothers me. Uh,
I, I don't know how many stories you
did for 60 minutes, but I've done a lot,
hundreds and hundreds and
many of them important,
important information that the public
should know, change should have been made.
And it just sort of evaporates.
I feel it evaporates.
So I guess people have said to me,
Oh, you have so much influence.
I fear that we don't, and I fear
because we're doing serious work.
That's what 60 minutes is really about.
So if we uncovers an injustice or if we
show some corruption and then nothing
happens,
it's very discouraging.
Sometimes you have to do,
uh,
you have to have the public
exposed to a story over and over.
It has to linger before
it really has an impact.
So 60 minutes does it,
and then someone else picks it up and
then maybe a congress woman makes a speech
about it and maybe someone tries to
pass a law. It has to go on and on. So,
you know, I sit in the studio and
I say to myself, okay, is this,
it's anybody going to do anything
about this? That's what I think.
But that's it. I mean 60
minutes still is, is, you know,
the news magazine a record,
but it's still average of 15 million
viewers every weekend. And that's, but,
but what happens? Did you ever do
a story the produce change? I did.
You did.
I did one and I was very,
very proud of which one was up the sugar
one and it really produce change and
produce some change.
It got the FDA to start really looking
at some of the classifications that they
had done. Um, but no, I
know exactly what you mean.
Where you do the story and your jazz
for months going, you know, this is,
this is going to be, it's going to blow
the lid off world and the little crack.
Maybe. So, I mean, that said,
do you think television news is,
is should we be planning the funeral?
Well, first of all, television
news has changed dramatically.
It's interesting that 60 minutes hasn't,
we'd still doing it the old way.
We still use the old stopwatch.
Um, the way I did it.
Well, but it's still a stop watch
and think Dick. And, uh, it's, uh,
we do, the stories are done
the same way, same ethics,
same standards, all of it. But most
news has changed because of the,
the shrinking of the time it takes between
the reporter learning something and
the reporter getting it out there.
When I started there were,
there was a whole day to think because
we worked in film and film had to be
processed and so you could really make
a hundred phone calls and you could
really suck your thumb for an
hour or two and think it over.
And then when we got videotape that time
was shorter and then we got cable and
those reporters had to be on the air
pretty quickly and now there's no time.
And that has changed the
nature of news dramatically.
So whether it's on
television or on the web, uh,
the, the nature of news, uh,
by definition is completely,
totally altered. I wouldn't,
if I were on doing daily reporting,
say, covering the White House,
I wouldn't begin to
know how to do it today.
And I really needed to make
a lot of phone calls and, uh,
I needed to understand it.
And I don't,
I don't understand how you can
just run out there. I, I wouldn't,
I don't do that at 60 minutes still.
So I'm kind of one of the lucky ones.
But I think that news is morphing,
I'm not saying it's better or worse,
actually I shouldn't be judging,
but it's definitely different and,
but I think the appetite
for news is enormous.
I think people want to know that they
want to devour and a lot of people want in
depth reporting. Oh, I mean our,
our audiences are enormous.
And websites that are doing in depth
investigative report it or surviving and
are healthy.
So I think people want this kind of work,
but not a lot of Pinot. Not, not enough.
Keeping on the news thing. Um, w
how do you feel about, you know,
the trend to so called comedy news?
Like Stuart and Oliver?
Yeah. Um, what,
what do I honestly think between you
and me and 30 800 million people,
I think they're brilliant.
It's satire and it's a,
it's a form of commentary
that people listen to.
People want to love. We started
out saying that, uh, Trump,
one of the reasons I think he's
successful is that he's really funny. Uh,
people want to laugh and if you feed
them the serial was sugar on top.
Um, they digest it. Uh,
I did the bill Maher show the other night.
He's brilliant.
He's hilarious. Um, I watch, well,
I used to watch the daily show.
I am, I enjoy it. It's, it's, it's
part of our life now. You know,
it's part of our society in our life.
It was a little discouraging to find out
that that was the only news some of our
children will listening to
that was a little hard to take.
But you know, my, as, as
the kids get a little older,
they start wanting something
a little more serious.
At least that's what I'm seeing
in my family. So I'm all for it.
Are you against it? Oh No, you
love it too. Oliver is this, oh,
it's the minutes. Absolutely.
Oliver's brilliant.
But Bill Maher really impressed
me the other night. They all are.
I think they're great.
Yeah.
So talking about the immediacy of news
versus the, the writing of the book, how,
how did the, um, how did
the process differ for you?
Were you in playing a lot of the same
skills and techniques, or was it a,
a new patent experience?
It was new, uh, well,
the reporting wasn't new,
but the writing was really hard because
the first draft that I showed my husband
who's a writer, he said this, this
is a series of 60 minutes pieces.
So I could,
I could write about 15 minutes and that,
but I to write long form,
like that really took
a lot of work for me.
I had to figure out how to
thread everything together.
I could do it for 15
minutes, and that was it. Uh,
but I really loved working on this book.
Um,
I met so many different kinds of
grandmothers and grandfathers across the
country. And to find out that
we're all in this together,
we grandparents were a society and our
children and how they relate to us,
meaning your generation,
how you relate to us is a
society where we're so connected.
We're all, we're all in this campaign.
So aware of how different we are,
but we are all the same grandparents.
Believe me, we're all the same.
We all love these kids intensely.
We all change in the way
we grandparent. Uh, we,
none of us can wait to
see those grandchildren.
We annoy our children because even if
we're not saying anything critical,
we are doing a little body language
thing that really irritates them.
And we're trying not to.
So we are one big community.
And I found that out and it was
very heartening. But writing was
a challenge. So you mentioned that, um,
you're disappointed that women haven't
reached higher levels in professions en
masse on mass.
Um,
and one thing that occurs to me is that
when grandparents are living close by to
their children and they're willing
to help out with the childcare,
that that may allow their
daughter to, um, you know,
be it in her profession longer
and reach higher levels.
Um, but it seems like in this world it's
a very international world and we have
people,
you know,
moving across continents to take jobs
and their parents don't always come with
them,
but a lot of them do,
a lot of them do.
Um,
and so I guess my question is what is
the responsibility of women who have
achieved high levels in their profession
to make sure that they mentor other
women or create policies in the workplace
to allow other women to rise when they
don't have as many advantages?
You know, support perhaps.
Well women should mentor
women, period. It's,
it's almost a given that we need
to help each other. So that is a,
is a necessity. We haven't
solved the problem of child care.
We just haven't. It's,
it's, it's what it's,
it may be one of the main reasons that
women don't achieve cause they break
their careers and half because they feel
they have to be home because they don't
trust the childcare situation,
the daycare situation. Um,
it's a conundrum.
I'm not a policy person.
I wish there were more policy people
working on it and more openness from our
elected officials to try
and create a structure,
a grid, some, some way for uh,
families to be able to go
to work with peace of mind.
Um, it's, it's,
it's a terrible unsolved
crisis in the country.
Childcare and uh,
I do come around at the end of my book
to say that this is the perfect way for
grandparents to,
and their extended retirement and
maybe not all grandparents move,
but there is a huge trend going on right
now of grandparents moving to be near
their grandchildren.
They do it selfishly.
They want to be in the babies' lives.
The smart parents,
the smart parents will overlook the
little critical elbowing and say,
we need you because you are a woman.
Going to work will never trust anybody
as much as she'll trust her mother with
her children. So, uh, for most,
for a lot of women that is the answer for
women whose parents cannot come and be
near them. Uh, we need, we need
more government to help us.
We do our societies or rotary clubs.
I mean something.
Uh,
so it's something I thought a
lot about when I wrote the book.
I also wrote about sour
get grand mothering, um,
parents who for any number of reasons.
I mean parents my age cannot be
with their own grandchildren.
Maybe they don't have any or maybe their
daughters just aren't or sons aren't
going to have them or maybe the daughter
in law is not going to have it but they
can sarragut grandparents,
another child somewhere else.
So it's a good,
it's a good way to end the take the last
30 years of your life cause we're going
to live a long time and we'll be healthy.
Most of us
and would that great thought. I want to
thank Leslie for coming to Google it.
Thank you.
I know you have to do the dash
cause you have to get up to San
Francisco and Battle Bay area traffic.
But we have books in the back. So
please, uh, stop by and grabs him.
And this is the best mother's Day
present you can give your mother.
I'm not kidding.
Grandmothers are adoring this book
because I'm talking about them. Thank you,
Leslie.
Thank you so much.